what's the big picture you know the
ultimate goal for the for the two of you
you know love where do you think were
you really trying to get to make movies
to make I mean to make movies and not
not have to kill ourselves doing it I
guess um I mean gonna kill yourself a
little bit but not entirely you know and
I think to be in a place where I mean
his answer is different from mine to be
honest um because for me I I don't want
to leave my day job I I like what I do
and I have summers off so for me I'd
like to be in a place where i have
enough experience and I have you know
enough to be able to use my 23 months I
mean if it to be able to actually go and
work on a set full time I mean for those
two months and that's a luxury that not
a lot of people have but for me that
would be sort of like a long-term a
long-term goal and I get to you pick and
choose my projects and um and then also
have a couple of them here and there
interspersed which is what I'm doing now
where I have them every so often um but
that I mean that's obviously different
than your gold yeah I think I mean my
goal is just to be able to continue
telling coal stories and working working
with great people i think um you know
when i started filming when i started
writing the idea was telling my stories
and i think that's changed over time
like um the collaboration aspect i think
it is more fun than any of the other
part like when you put a when you put an
awesome team together when you could get
to work with other you know other people
who are brilliant and awesome and what
they do and getting to be around that I
think it is great so for me the
experience of working with others to
tell cool and entertaining stories is
most rewarding and
but I want to continue to do and how
those shoots fit into this bigger
picture I think it's a chance like
chutes and ladders was our are diving
into webserie shoots as our diving into
features I think the difference this
time is that you know we do have an
awesome team I think chutes and ladders
we're really on our own learning how to
do it all um so you know we have buy it
by default we had to work in all of the
different areas so that we got to learn
from it so that you know now that we're
working with a team we can have a better
understand you know what everyone does
in respect that a little more so our
goal is just to you know get something
out to an audience get something more we
had to to learn something or get to you
know get to work with with awesome
talented people and build from there and
hopefully you know while we do all this
creating this story building build an
audience at the same time hopefully
people will appreciate what we're doing
yeah and so much of it is just like you
know your your next projects come your
next project comes from the people
you've already worked with you know
people who you've already built
relationships with and and what we found
a lot is you know and when you're
working with friends to it doesn't
really feel like work and that's why we
all kind of do it and and people start
sort of doing things for other friends
like oh like I have this really cool
project that I've created because I want
you to do this or I think you're an
amazing actress with this so I've
written this for you and now we're going
to work together again and I think just
getting to that point where it's like
like that's consistent thing where where
everyone is just sort of contributing to
this success of everyone you know like
our friend successes our success in our
successes are friends and just having
that spirit of collaboration and and you
know continuing to sort of all push and
just get something great that's that's
out there
you